ROLE IN ONGOING PORTANTINO HERE
PORTANTINO HERE BATES BATES
HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE T
RAZA HELL HILL HERE JONES BY
CASKEY HERE MY CASKEY HERE. SO
WE HAVE A QUORUM- WE HAVE
FIFTEEN BILLS TO HEAR TODAY
FOUR OF WHICH ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
TO PASS A MOTION FROM- WITH A
DO PASS MOTION THE REMAINING
BILLS ARE ALSO SPENDS ITEMS. SB
SEVEN OH TWO BY MISTER HILL IS
STILL ON THE FILE BUT WILL BE
REPORTED AS A TWENTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT- SO THAT WILL
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED WITH US
WITH SB SEVEN OH TWO. AS A
REMINDER- I'D LIKE TO REITERATE
THAT. MEMBERS IN TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF A BILL
TODAY- PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS YOU
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY IN THE
PAST. AND WE HAVE- MISTER
ROGERS HERE MISTER BRADFORD
CHEER. FOR DISMISSING MISTER
JONES- AND SO OUR FIRST. DO
PASS BILL IS SB TWO EIGHTY ONE
BY MR WIENER. ON FIREARM SALES
OF THE CAL PALACE THE CENTER
WITH A VIEW TO COME. AND SHARE
WITH US SB TWO EIGHTY ONE. AND
NOTE THAT IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIR- THIS
LEGISLATION. RESULTS FROM
DECADES OF ADVOCACY BY THE
COMMUNITY TO AND THE GUN SHOWS
AT THE COW PALACE IN A LONG
HISTORY IN LEGISLATURE- EARLIER
THIS YEAR- TO ME A YEAR AGO- I
A- ALONG WITH SOME OF AND TING.
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
PERMANENTLY BANNED THE GUN
SHOWS AND TO TRANSFER THE LAND-
TO LOCAL CONTROL- WE MOVED OUT
THROUGH THREE POLICY COMMITTEES
AND THEN WE MADE A TO YOUR
BILL- BECAUSE WE WANT TO WE SAW
THE GOVERNOR WAS MAKING SOME
CHANGES TO THE COMPOSITION OF
THE BOARD- THE CAL PALACE HAS
NOW VOLUNTARILY AND THAT THE
GUN SHOWS- AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
MADE STRONG APPOINTMENTS TO THE
BOARD- AND SO WE'RE REMOVING
WE'VE- WE'VE- BEEN MOVING- THE
LAND USE PROVISIONS FROM THE
BILL. IT'S A STRAIGHT UP GUN
SHOW BAND- I DO WANT TO SAID
THE REASON WHY WE'RE PROCEEDING
WITH THE LEGISLATION IS THAT
THE NRA AND OTHER GUN GROUPS
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BELIEVE THE
CAL PALACE INTO REINSTATING. OF
THE GUN SHOWS AND IN FACT THE
KALPOE SUPPORT UP ALMOST WENT
IN THAT DIRECTION A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO AND THEN BACKED OFF
AND SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED-
THAT THEY MIGHT REVERSE COURSE
AND NOT TWENTY ONE TO MAKE IT A
PERMANENT STATUTORY BAN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. YES MISTER CHEN
MEMBERS ARE LAYING BEHALF OF
MARYLAND IN BREED. AND CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS MORNING TO GIVE. THANK
YOU. OUR OTHER WITNESSES ANY
OPPOSITION. MINISTER OF FINANCE
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS-
JULIE UNDER THERE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID I
DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THIS
MEASURE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES- ANY QUESTIONS
SIGNAL QUESTIONS THIS THEIR
MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER
WINNER WOULD LIKE FLOWS REQUEST
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION ND WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D TO RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL. HILL AYE CHIU.
MY CASKEY. HI MY CASKEY I. THE
BILL IS FIVE TO ONE- WE HOLD IT
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR MISTER
JONES AND WE'LL MOVE ON YOUR
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU GOT IT. WE
WILL MOVE TO MISTER ARCHULETA I
BELIEVE IS NEXT. SB FOUR
EIGHTY. ON RADIOLOGIST AGAIN
RESEARCH A LOT OF THIS IS A DO
PASS SO BREVITY'S APPRECIATED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND A
AND- MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR-
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT SB FOUR EIGHTY THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO EVALUATE WHAT
STEPS CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE TO
HELP IMPROVE THE LICENSURE OF
ADVANCED PRACTICE OF
RADIOLOGICAL TECHNICIANS. THE
ADVANCE OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHES BY THIS
BILL WILL EVALUATE WHAT IS
BEING DONE IN CALIFORNIA IN
THIS SPACE. AND WILL BE DONE TO
HELP MEET THE EVER INCREASING
DEMAND FOR MEDICAL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE COST OF THIS
BILL IS A MINIMAL. AMOUNT IS
ESTIMATED AT FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO COORDINATE
THE RELEASE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
REPORT AND THE COMMITTEE- WHICH
A COMMITTEE CREATES. WITH ME
TODAY HAVE PAT MORON
REPRESENTED THE AMERICAN
REGISTRY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND ALSO HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU MAY HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU. HI MISTER MOORE AND-
CJ MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH THEIR
AND READ MISTER SITS
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
REGISTRY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS WITH SPONSORING
THE BILL IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- BONTA A DRAG THIS OUT ANY
LONGER WHAT- MISTER ACTUALLY
THE SAID IS A ONE POINT AND WE
ENCOURAGE AND I BOTH. THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS BOB ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RADIOLOGICAL
SOCIETY POSITIONS WILL
SUPERVISORS ARE RESOURCE IN
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE OUT THERE SAYING NO
RUSH THE MICROPHONE IS OUR
OPPOSITION. IS THERE A REPORT
FROM THE FILE NO FILE. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE MOTION. AND THEN
DID YOU ACCEPT THE MOMENT
GUESTS. ENTER ALREADY LIKE
DíAS YEAH THE MANDATORY
ADOPTED SO THE BILL BEFORE US
IS AS AMENDED WRECKED. IT THE
MOTION TO PASS BUT THIS BILL
OPERATORS TO PASS CORRECT SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHTS WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D RAZA.
DRAWS ARE AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES Y. CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I.
SO IT'S SIX ZERO HOLDEN OPEN
FOR MISTER JONES AND- WE WILL
GO TO MISTER MONEY THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER
ARCHULETA. MISTER MONEY WE HAVE
THE SEA OTTER TAX CONTRIBUTION
FUND. ALL. GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN RENAMES
THE CALIFORNIA SEA OTTER FUND
THE SEA OTTER VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION FUND AND EXTENDS
THE FUN TO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS HAVE
GENEROUSLY CONTRIBUTED TO THE
SEA OTTER FUND FUNDS ARE USED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE USES THE FUNDS IT
RECEIVES FOR SEA OTTER
CONSERVATION INCLUDING
INCREASED INVESTIGATION
PREVENTION AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS RELATED TO SEA OTTER
MORTALITY THE COSTA CONSERVANCY
USES THE FUNDS IT RECEIVES TO
HELP SCIENTISTS BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CAUSES OF SEA
OTTER MORTALITY AND DEVELOP
GUIDANCE TO AID IN OUR
RECOVERY- I WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
IN MISTER CHAIR- I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT. WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS STEVE BAKER WITH
ORDINARY DISSOCIATES FOR THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS OF
VOLUNTEERED. SEVERAL MILLION
DOLLARS OF THEIR OWN TAX MONEY
TO HELP FUND THIS CONSERVATION
AND RESEARCH ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH IS NECESSARY AND SO WE
VERO DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- IN
ADDITION TO EVERYTHING THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN SAID I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THAT THE FUND
HAS SUPPORTED PUBLIC EDUCATION
PROJECTS WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
PROJECTS AND OTHER IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION AND NONE OF THAT
WOULD BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT THIS
FUN SO WE A- REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OUR GOOD MORNING. OR AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF ONE OF THE MEAN ON
A WITHOUT A BUNCH CALIFORNIA-
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AS
LONG AS WELL AS THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY ASSUME AND- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS N SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SIR OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE IS THERE REPORT NO FILE NO
FILE- WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AND
URGE HERE FIVE VOTES THANK YOU
SIR MOTION. MR HELL MOTIONS-
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
DORADO DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES Y. CASKEY. HI BUT CASKEY
I. SO THAT BILL IS SIX ZERO FOR
THE ON CALL FOR MISTER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS MS GALGIANI YOU
HAVE A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WHAT
YOU WANTED TO PRESENT-
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT IS GOING
TO. GO TO SUSPENSE SO PLEASE
COME UP AND TELL US. ABOUT SB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
I THE U. S. B. THREE EIGHT
EIGHT ASSEMBLY CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA ADOPTED TWO
PIECES OF LEGISLATION ONE WAS
BY SENATOR RAINY AND ANOTHER
WAS BY SENATOR SPEAR. AND IT
WAS INTENDED TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
ENSURE THAT WE ADDRESS MISSING
PERSON CASES IN A CERTAIN WAY
AND AT THAT TIME- DUE TO
CONCERN THAT WAS A NEW PROGRAM
AND AGAIN THIS WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO. THERE WAS A CLAUSE IN THE
LAW THAT ALLOWED COUNTIES TO
VOTE TO OPT OUT OF FOLLOWING
THE STATE REQUIREMENTS. THE
SENATOR JACQUI SPEARS BILL
REQUIRE THAT A DATABASE BE SET
UP FOR THAT MISSING PERSONS
COULD HAVE THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. COME FORWARD AND
PROVIDE DNA IN THE EVENT THAT
THE MISSING PERSON WOULD LATER
BE FOUND AND THEN SENATOR
RAINEY'S BILL ADDRESSED HELL
AND IDENTIFIED. REMAINS OF. OF
LOVED ONES WOULD BE HANDLED.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THE COUNTIES COMPLY
THERE ARE ONLY A FEW COUNTIES
THAT AREN'T COMPLYING ALL OF
THE TIME THERE ARE SOME
COUNTIES THAT ACTUALLY HAVE
THEIR MISSING PERSONS LISTED ON
FACEBOOK. BUT IF THEY'RE LISTED
ON FACEBOOK AND THE INDIVIDUALS
REMAINS ARE FOUND SOMEWHERE
ELSE THEY WILL THEY WILL NEVER
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
IDENTIFIED OF DNA IS NOT TAKEN.
THIS THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS CAME TO LIGHT TO MY
COMMUNITY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE WHEN THERE WERE TWO
SERIAL KILLERS WHO WERE ACTIVE
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
AND NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SOME
OF YOUR MEMBER THEY- SUPPOSEDLY
KILLED SEVENTY TWO INDIVIDUALS
THERE WERE FIVE MISSING PERSONS
WHO WERE RECOVERED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TWO WERE FROM
CALAVERAS COUNTY. CHEVY WHEELER
WHO WENT MISSING IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE CINDY VANDER HIDING
NINETY EIGHT AND THEN THREE
WOMEN FROM A WELL FORTY FIVE
FEET DEEP- JOANNE HOBSON WHO
HAD BEEN MISSING SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE KEEP BILLY BILLY
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. AND
ONE ONE AND WHO TO THIS DAY
REMAINS UNIDENTIFIED AND SHE'S
ON IDENTIFIED BECAUSE EITHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT DIDN'T TAKE DNA
FROM THE FAMILY OR THE FAMILY
DIDN'T COME FOR HER SHE DIDN'T
HAVE FAMILY BUT NONE THE LESS
SHE TO THIS DAY REMAINS.
UNIDENTIFIED DNA WAS TAKEN FROM
HER REMAINS BUT WHAT IT MEANS
IS THAT SHE WAS CREMATED AS AN
ANTIGEN SO WHILE THIS BILL IS
PAID IS HAVING COST. A PERHAPS
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS I
DON'T EVEN BELIEVE IT'S THAT
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO FEW
COUNTIES THAT AREN'T ACTUALLY
DOING THIS ANYMORE BECAUSE IT'S
TWENTY YEARS THAT HAVE PASSED
SINCE THE TIME. I WOULD ALSO
ARGUE THAT WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
IS FOUND AND BY DEBT A NON HIS
THAT. A STATE AND THE DOG. THAT
IF YOU ARE LOOKING STRUGGLE THE
FINANCIAL. COST TO COUNTY TO
BURY THAT ENDED AS IN A GEN THE
HIGH TAKING. KING DEAN A. DOES
NOT TAKE THEM. EIGHT CAUGHT BOB
I THE IN THE MAIL AND IT'S A
MATTER OF. THE REPORT. MY
OFFICE HEALTH AND REALLY WE'VE
HAD SEVERAL IN THE- ATTY TO THE
TO GENERAL STATED. HAS FAMILIES
CAME FOR. DURING THAT TIME WHO
HAD LEFT INTO A COME AND SO I'M
SURE WITH YOU THAT I. GONE
WORKED WITH MY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE AG'S OFFICE
TO ENSURE THAT FAMILY MEMBERS
HAVE THEIR LOVED ONES ADDED TO
THE STATE'S DATABASE IT WAS
ALWAYS THE INTENTION. THAT
WOULD WORK THAT WAY AND AGAIN
IT'S BEEN AND STATUTES CENTS.
FOR TWENTY YEARS IT'S JUST THAT
THERE'S A FEW COUNTIES WHO. CAN
OPT NOT TO PARTICIPATE SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
CLARIFYING IN TECHNICAL AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT IT WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE SUSPENSE FILE.
THANK YOU. ME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NO NOT AT THIS POINT
XIN SIR FILE NEW FILE NO FILE
SO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING
OBVIOUS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE- WILL WHICH WE WILL
BE DEALING WITH ON THURSDAY
WHEN WE DO THE SUSPENSE FIVE
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR MAKING SO
LET'S GO TO THE TOP OF OUR
LIST. I'LL DO MINE AT THE END
LET'S GO THROUGH EVERYTHING AND
MISTER JONES COME. HE'S ON HIS
WAY OKAY SO SB THIRTY THREE BY
MISS SKINNER ON ELECTRONIC
BENEFITS AND TRANSFERS FOR
ANYBODY HERE SPEAKING IN.
SUPPORT OUR OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE THERE'S NO FILE- IS THERE
MOTION WITHOUT OBJECTION IT
GOES TO SUSPENSE RIGHT SB
THIRTY THREES ON TO SCRATCH SB
SIX NINETY TWO AS ANYBODY HERE
TO SPEAK ON SB SIX NINETY TWO
CANNABIS TRADE SAMPLES. FOR
AGAINST. THE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SIGNAL QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX NINETY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE- SB
FORTY FIVE BY MISTER ALLEN.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION BOND ACT I
SEE PEOPLE RUNNING UP TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRED SENATORS- AND CAN UNITS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS EFFORT WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE- SEVERAL
OTHER BOND PROPOSALS WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE ARE I'M GOING TO BE VERY
HAPPY TO ENGAGE ON THOSE AND
PROVIDE- SERVER AT A SET HOME
SET OF AMENDMENTS TO ALL THOSE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BATH A LOSS ON BEHALF
OF WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA- ALSO
LOOKING FOR TO THE DISCUSSIONS
AS WE- COME TOGETHER WITH TWO
HOUSES ON THE BONDS AND-
ENCOURAGE INCREASED FUNDING FOR
WATER RECYCLING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTERS
FOR AGAINST NOBODY IS THERE A
FILE. NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FORTY FIVE. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
MISTER ALLEN ON STATE HIGHWAYS
RELINQUISHMENT. YOU GUYS DID
WORK OUT THAT ONE PIECE OF IT-
SO ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION. THE FILE NO FILE
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE WE'VE DONE
TO EIGHTY ONE WILL MOVE ON TO
SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER WIENER ON ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS SIR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SIR FILE YOU
KNOW FILE SEEING NO HANDS RUSH
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO CSUS
BANDS MISTER WHITE COW SKIS
FAVORITE BILL OF ALL TIME IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OPPOSITION.
ON THE FIRST MISTER WHITE CAST-YES A GOOD QUESTION ON THE
FISCAL IMPACTS GO AHEAD HI TIM
SMELLS ARE REPRESENTING- WINE
INSTITUTE- WE ARE JOINED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS THE FAMILY WINE
MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA THE
DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL OF
UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA
ARTESANAL GUILD AND THE WINE
AND SPIRITS WHOLESALERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. SHERMAN MEMBERS DON'T
SLIPPER FOR THE CALIFORNIA BEER
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO REMAIN
IN OPPOSITION. THE BILL MOVES
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BOTTLE
BILL OVER TO DISTRIBUTORS
WHICH- MAKES NO FISCAL SENSE AT
ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION SIR FILE. NO
FILE MISTER WHITE KOWSKI WAS
LISTENING AND TOOK COPIOUS
NOTES AND WILL BE ADDRESSING.
IT SAVES MONEY- WITHOUT
OBJECTION OR COMMENT SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT BY MS
GALGIANI PRESENTED THE SHED NO
SPEAKERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION IT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB FOR
SEVENTEEN IN WALKING A COME
BACK TO SB FOUR FOUR FOUR BY MR
UMBERG AND UC BERKELEY IRVINE
LAW SCHOOLS ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT. ANY OPPOSITION IS OUR
FILE FILE NO FILE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP. SB FOUR FOUR FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WE'VE DONE
FOR AT AND FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
REMOVE ON TO MISTER STEARNS SP
FIVE NINETY SIX ON IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT. SURE
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE A FILE FILE. THERE IS NO
FILE SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
NINETY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE ALSO BY MR
STERN ON FIRE PREVENTION.
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. SIR FILE
NO FILE SEEING NO HAN GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. GO TO SUSPENSE
MISTER BRADFORD HAS S. C. R.
SIXTY NINE ONE PRISONER WAGES
IS THERE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION. YOUR
SUPPORT I HOPE SO- IS THERE
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE ON SCR
SIXTY NINE THERE'S NO FILE-
SEEING NO HANDS OTHER THAN
MISTER BRADFORD TO GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SCR SIXTY
NINE. WILL GO ON SAYS SPENCE-
LET'S LIFT THE- ALL ON SB TWO
EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR JONES.
JONES NOW. FINAL VOTE WAS FIVE
TO TWO ON SB FOUR EIGHTY
MISTRUST LETTER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR JONES.
JONES I. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO ON SB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
MISTER MANNING. THE MOSTLY
ABSENT MEMBERS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR JONES
JONES I. SEVEN ZERO- WE HAVE
ONE BILL LAUGHED WHICH IS THE-
VICTIMS COMPENSATION. AT THAT
PROCESS NOW. HILL FILED SEC.
YEAH. THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR I'M PRESENTING
US BEFORE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS
ONE OF THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD CLAIMS A TRADITION THAT
THE APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
PRESENTS THESE CLAIMS BILLS
LUNCH THERE WORKED OUT SO THIS
BILL WOULD APPROPRIATE
1-003-600-0700 EIGHTY DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD FOR
THE PAYMENT OF A STATE CLAIM
RELATED TO THE AROUND HIS
CONVICTION OF MOON SHADOW NAOMI
HAGGART IN THIS CASE THE
APPELLATE COURT REVERSED A
CONVICTION OF ESCAPE FROM
CUSTODY OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AGREED SHE WAS INNOCENT. THE
BOARD AGREED BUT THIS
DETERMINATION AND RECOMMENDED A
COMPENSATION FOR NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN DAYS OF
INCARCERATION- NEIL AND S. FROM
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
I DO KNOW THAT THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE AG- AND IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THOSE IN YOUR
COMMENTS THAT WOULD BE GREAT I
THINK THEY WERE RELATED TO YOU
AND PLEASE TAKE IT AWAY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON ILLINOIS FOR THE
VICTIM COMP. BOARD I AM THAT
CHECK WAS- JUST ASKED ABOUT-
WHETHER- FIJI PERSONALLY
APPEARED AT THE HEARING I'M
CHECKING FOR CLARIFICATION ON
THAT- I'LL BE ABLE TO GET BACK
TO YOU SHORTLY SHOULD BE THIS
AFTERNOON. TO CONFIRM THAT.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ANY
OF. MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. ANY
OPPOSITION. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS. FILE A YES I
KNEW WERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THEN NOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
PORTANTINO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A. IN MOVED BY
SENATOR Y. KASKI CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE BATES NO BATES
NO BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D TO
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO WAY CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE THE BILL IS OUT BY
THE. TWO THOUSAND. THE BILL IS
OUT FIVE TWO TWO THAT DISPENSES
WITH OUR FILE TODAY WE HAVE OUR
MEETING ON THURSDAY. SO ARE
AFTER SESSION. IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WE WILL HAVE OUR
MEETING ON THURSDAY AFTER
SESSION TO DEAL WITH THE
SUSPENSE FILE OF THE SENATE TO
YOUR BILLS. BUT THAT THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING. THE OTHER FOUR
LETTER.